i
stayed out of codepen for the most part
i wrote some early p i r an early piece
that's basically was
pretty much echoing the mainstream view
which was that we needed to take some
pretty significant actions yeah this was
in march april 2020
and then i decided to go by san
francisco and i basically stopped
working on it but the campaign
i had a lot of people that were and you
may know that steve kirsh is on my board
my non-profit oh yeah so steve cruz is a
long time friend and supporter has been
on my board of directors and i know he's
a friend of yours now
um
but i knew very little about it i stayed
most of it i saw that you and claire
were fighting
i saw this thing going i was trying to
be nice
claire was fighting yeah
um
so
you know i'm interested in how you look
back on the last couple of years and
what you take from it um i will say i
have been censored
on facebook for climate information
um and then the only time i've ever been
censored on instagram was just
a week ago
for
for posting images of my tweets
saying that masked mandates were
pseudoscience and what i tweeted out was
from the new york times it was from
david leonard his piece on mass mandates
so the only i've ever had censored
um catch me tell me where what what
when you look back for the last two
years
and and also just catch me with your
views because i know i'm sure you're you
know i know your viewers know but but
how would you summarize it um
yeah i mean uh
there are a couple different threads
there yeah one
personally
i don't think i had any choice about
what i did i'm sure there are small
things i could alter there are a couple
things i got wrong which i i wish i
hadn't but i thought
actually in light of how much one could
get wrong that actually
we got almost everything right okay and
that that's important but i mean
basically
um when i
when i came into the the public eye i
came into the public eye for being the
person who faced with an accusation of
racism
just said
no no that's not true right
i can establish that if you're willing
to listen
and so the point is i got famous as it
were for
saying difficult true things yes
that's what i always do right right and
the problem is sometimes
it wins you
friends
and then it will turn some of those
people to enemies on the next topic
right and my feeling is look
you either signed up for somebody who
will do that in which case you know
there's nothing that guards me against
being wrong other than the fact that i
try really hard not to be wrong because
frankly reversing course is
painful and right costly
um but you know you're either signed up
for somebody who will say the
uncomfortable stuff no matter how many
people disagree with them and no matter
how forcefully or you're not really on
board with that and so my feeling is
okay
i did what i always do
in this case
it had um
terrible effects
in many regards i mean heather and i
lost
more than half our family income in a
single hour as youtube demonetized both
our channels they remain demonetized wow
um for things that we were right about
right
um so they need a best-selling book
best-selling book we don't know how well
it would have done if we hadn't been
actively accused of spreading
misinformation which has now been
redefined
um by the federal government by the
department of homeland security is mal
information have you have you gotten the
memo
no
there are now three types of uh
informational terrorism
one of them is misinformation that's
when you're incorrect about something
the next one is disinformation that's
when you're incorrect and you know it
intentionally and mal information is
when you're correct in a way that causes
distrust of the government
so that might be where you ended up
running foul of uh instagram or wow
well
so back me up in terms of
um all right what did you get right what
did you get wrong and what is the jury
still out about on
okay
well there's a question about what the
evidence says yeah there's a question
about what
people have now acknowledged and there
are big gaps here so okay i would say
that there are um
several major threads to the
conversation
the first one is
where did the virus come from
i was very early on lab week
i i won't go all the way back into the
history but it became obvious very
quickly
that
while some of the evidence was ambiguous
all of the evidence that wasn't
ambiguous pointed to the lab and not to
the wet market or to a cave okay
and you know i said so okay um
and i was pretty clear that the street
you know i wasn't 100 sure of anything
but um so the three big issues
origin
there's origin masks and
masks
lockdowns
and vaccines are those would you say
those are the four big issues really no
i would say the three biggest issues are
early treatment and vaccine safety and
effectiveness okay i would say there is
a fourth that the public has yet to
really understand
is even an issue but it is which is uh
the evolution of viral variants where
are they coming from why do they look
the way they do what would we do if we
wanted to shut them down right um so
that's a fourth thread and then there's
the lockdown and math question masks are
actually one thing i got wrong
early on i thought i was one of the
first people uh anywhere that i was
aware of who was masking in fact at the
point that covid
became it became clear coveted was going
to transform the way we were interacting
at least for the time being
we we had a our studio was downtown and
my son and i would go
late at night when we wouldn't interact
with anybody
and we would we took all of the
equipment to do our podcast out of this
office space that we knew we were
abandoning and we moved it into our
house and we would go to the home depot
and we would buy the stuff for our set
and we built this thing
and
i got a reputation
as the bandit of the hardware store
because i was masking
right nobody else was masking anything
this is all in portland yeah nobody's
masking in portland early on no no no i
was masked way before they were and is
your view now that masks are you i mean
do like n95s or you think n95s don't
work uh i wouldn't say n95s don't work i
would say if properly worn n95 masks
have some effect right but the mask
mandates don't require an impact 95. yes
the cloth masks don't seem to work at
all i was struck on social media how how
much people mixed up masks and mask
mandates
right yeah they're the same thing and
they're not um
right so okay so that's easy so then so
then what about the vaccines well hold
on masks i got wrong okay um
lockdowns i think i got right
which was there was a place for
lockdowns but they needed to be
more intense than they were
they needed to be short duration and
they needed to be paired with excellent
quality testing which frankly we still
don't have right which i don't know i
can't imagine why we don't have it i
think that's a problem money would solve
and the fact that we haven't dedicated
enough money to have tests that are
worth anything is conspicuous to me but
i would have had let's say a yes painful
six-week very intense lockdown and the
reason for that is that that gives it
enough time most of the transmission was
at home
so six weeks gives it enough time to
burn through
you know places where we are corralled
together
such that at the point you lift that six
week mandate you have a small number of
places where active covet still exists
and if you had good testing you could
figure out where they were and you could
apply some very local solutions that we
the rest of us could have gone back
um to life
given that we never had good tests
i would not favor that plan but
were i in charge i would have invested
very an asian east asian approach korea
hong kong well
yes and no
you know good
uh good tests would be key
and then a epidemiologically sensible
lockdown in which the virus was given a
chance to be not contagious in any given
group
so that
you know you would have hot spots but
you could find them and the rest of us
wouldn't be infecting each other so i
think i had that right but we don't know
okay we didn't do that okay
um
lab origin i think i clearly had right
and i think almost everybody now gets it
so the other two are early treatment and
vaccines early treatment have vaccines
and you asked for vaccines first yeah um
i initially was excited about the
vaccines i initially assumed that i
would be vaccinated
i
became and heather and i really became
immediately alarmed at the point that
the vaccines were announced because of
what was said about them right heather
and i because we're biologists looked at
what we were being told about these
vaccines and on the one hand
what a marvelous
fascinating way to vaccinate right this
is a really radically different way of
inducing an immune response and you know
in our book which was finished we
literally emerged from writing the last
uh or the
first
uh draft of the book that we then
submitted to the publisher
we emerged we were in the uh ecuador and
amazon figuring
finalizing the book we emerged back to
where our phones connected to the world
and heard about
the novel coronavirus
and so anyway the book was written
before
comet it has an addendum that includes
kelby but the book is not about cobit
and
in the book we say vaccination is one of
three great triumphs of medical
technology right the other two being
surgery and antibiotics
so we're big fans of vaccines and these
vaccines are
really fascinating and we were compelled
that it was a pretty interesting idea
but we were absolutely alarmed at being
told that they were safe
because they couldn't possibly be
right we didn't know that they did harm
but the point is safe means you know it
doesn't do harm
and the gamble involved in this radical
intervention
in
the immune system
uh was so great that i thought well
you're you're telling us you know that
these aren't going to cause
autoimmune disorders or
tumors or neurological disruptions
right it was just the number of things
that these could induce
that you would have to you would need
years following them to know for sure
that they didn't do it and we were told
oh no they're they're safe and we know
it right accelerated the process of
testing these are safe and it's like
whoa i know you just lied to me right
and so the fact that they lied to us and
said they were safe when they couldn't
possibly know that
caused us to think
we want you know we weren't initially
eligible
um because we're healthy and uh not that
old and so we were like okay we'll wait
as long as we can and we'll give time
for an adverse event signal to show up
because that's the safer thing to do and
the longer we waited the more
frightening that picture became right
so
what is the state of this discussion
well
i don't think most of the public has any
idea yet
how
much harm has been done
right i don't think the public has
caught on to the fact that
we either have no information on how
dangerous they are because the one
system we have for collecting that
information is now dismissed
or we do know how dangerous they are and
it's incredibly dangerous but we have an
adverse event signal that is greater
than all the other vaccines combined you
know over the course of 30 years so the
signal we built a system to detect an
adverse event signal
that
uh
that system
is firing off you know alarms at an
unprecedented level and we're ignoring
it
now the public does know about
myocarditis and it knows about blood
clots and so it knows that there's some
sort of an issue but it hasn't yet
understood how deep the problem is
hopefully we will stop gaslighting the
injured
you know and find out how many there are
find out how sick they are and find out
whether we can treat them um but for the
moment we're still pretending that it's
a tiny tiny number of people which uh
seems very unlikely
and then there's the toughest of all of
these which is early treatment
um so we were effectively told that
there was
um
you know you could either
face covet
or
you could be vaccinated
well that's only because we ignored
the medicines that really do work right
and what white i mean i i said steve
kirsh was advocated this of course i saw
this 60 minutes
that covered one of these trials which
was right here in berkeley by the way at
the local
um
horse
uh arena where the workers remember this
yeah yeah
the uh the workers got these two
different early treatments so for flu
boxing yeah yeah so what like what's the
deal there well
the deal is unfortunately
um
of a nature
that
you know
there are two mutually exclusive ways of
viewing it either those of us who
believe early treatment works
are all
woefully misinformed
and
incapable of seeing that we've made an
error
or
something has endeavored
has spent mightily to prevent
information
on early treatments that work from
making it to your doctor your pharmacist
you know the mainstream media
i don't think this is ambiguous at all
um the evidence is quite strong
but
the
sophistication of the campaign that has
been marshaled to prevent that
information from being understood is
stunning but it was on i mean fluoxamine
zesty loxamine fluoxamine was once it
was on 60 minutes and it was incredibly
compelling so what happened with that
particular that's a great question
because here okay so we've got
fluvoxamine which is uh
usually used for depression
um we've got a strong signal that is
very effective against covid
um
it's not part of the standard of care
and why is that because there's no money
to be made it's the obvious answer
because it's a generic at this point is
that why yeah is it the story is the
story i've heard the story where sort of
one of the reasons they
that they thought that these drugs were
that fluvoxamine or other psychiatric
drugs at work was because psychiatric
patients were not getting coveted is
that true
is that a sort of urban myth um i don't
know steve would be the guy yeah to ask
about that um i have not been
particularly excited about fluvoxamine
because i think
by and large you know these
psychological medications are a faustian
bargain and we have better drugs we have
drugs that work better than that what
are those um
here's where things get very ugly yeah
there are two primary and then there are
a bunch of other things that seem to
contribute okay the two are irmectin and
hydroxychloroquine okay
now hydroxychloroquine is one i got
wrong
i did not spot that early i thought i
bought the story right at the point that
trump talked about hydroxychloroquine
and then
you know
the scientific chorus erupted and said
it doesn't work we thought it was
promising but it doesn't work i assumed
that that made sense it turns out it
doesn't it's a very important
anticoagula drug with very low toxicity
and the tests that were done actually
specifically gave people a toxic dose in
order
to make the uh
the compound
unthinkable
but it does it does there's very strong
evidence that hydroxychloroquine is very
effective against covid
there is equally strong evidence
that ivermectin works
iremectin has two utilities in this
crisis one of them is that it is
extremely effective at treating people
who have coveted now the earlier you
give it the better one of the ways that
the
evidence for its utility has been
obscured
is by making what are called
underpowered trials that do things like
treat people with too little or treat
them too late in the course of the
disease for it to be effective
but if you treat people early with a
sufficient dose iremectin turns out to
be very effective at keeping people from
getting severely ill
and it's extremely low toxicity
so there's
effectively no reason not to give it and
it's been used effectively in many parts
of the world
to control the pandemic
now the really interesting thing about
it is because it's so safe as a drug and
it really is among the safest drugs that
we have
it can be given without
a positive covered test in other words
if you think you have covid
we can just give it to you
we're not putting you at significant
risk what's more because it has
prophylactic effectiveness we can give
it to the people you live with and keep
them from getting sick
so
i did get one thing wrong with
ivermectin which was i put too much
weight on a study that came out of
argentina which said uh study was
over a thousand people
and it appeared to be 100 effective
and i thought well
that's pretty powerful evidence
there was then some concern about the
quality of the data
i didn't want to get it wrong so i
actually contacted the primary
investigator i said can i see the data
set
he did not provide the data set and i
became further along that there was
something about this study that um was
unreliable i believe we now know what
happened which was that
uh
this
researcher hector carvalho ran the study
but he ran it as a tally he didn't keep
the data in the way that a proper
scientific experiment would what he
basically did was counted
case numbers of uh cases of covet and
it's sloppy
so when i discovered that that was the
case i went to my audience and i said
look i have
said that this study suggests that this
is nearly 100 effective as a
prophylactic i would now rate the
quality of the study you know i would
give it to zero evidentiary weight and
that changes the overall picture for
iron mechanism's value a bit but not
much
so
i got that wrong and i got
hydroxychloroquine wrong and i got masks
wrong
um
but other than that
i think i got just about everything
right and so what's the um and so you're
what would your and what do your critics
accuse you of
um
what is your response to your critics
my response to my critics is that they
don't actually know what they're talking
about but what is their criticism what
is their criticism of you and what's
that the criticism
uh the one that is most intense
at this point is
you got ivermectin wrong we now know it
doesn't work
and you uh for reasons of pride or
because
you've made money or something like this
won't admit it
now frankly
even at this late date if i thought i
would become didn't work the best thing
i could do
for my family for my future would be to
say hey i got this one wrong here's how
it happened but it doesn't work
it's just not the case it does work and
the fact that people have been
um
kept from having access to this drug
and then been left with a choice do you
want to be vaccinated or not when the
real choice is of the available
treatments and preventatives
which is the best
uh from the point of view of the cost
benefit analysis
right
likely
for almost everybody and maybe even for
everybody these vaccines were far too
radical in their mechanism of action to
be contemplated and for most people they
could be kept safe with these
alternatives
problem is there wasn't any money to be
made
[Music]